d'abord merci de m'accueillir parmi vous
c'était évidemment un plaisir et ça va
me permettre à moi même de faire le
point et de prendre un petit peu de
recul par rapport à des événements
nombreux qui se sont déroulées depuis le
mois de janvier et qui ont sans doute
mis en lumière un certain nombre de
fracture qui traversent notre société et
dont l école finalement se retrouve être
la résonance la vitrine et la façon dont
nous veillons à répondre aux difficultés
qui se présentent aujourd'hui et que je
résumerais en disant que les attentats
de janvier dernier ont eu pour effet et
on peut s'en réjouir que beaucoup de
français ont tourné leurs yeux vers
l'école en se demandant comment mieux
éduquer nos enfants pour que de telles
choses ne puisse plus jamais se
reproduire dans la foulée vous le savez
l'école s'est mobilisée notamment en
demandant à ce que dans chaque
établissement scolaire soit respecté une
minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes
laquelle minute de silence a été dans un
certain nombre d'heures monde endroit
perturbé pour diverses raisons qui nous
ont amenés collectivement à nous
interroger évidemment à réunir la
communauté éducative comme je lé fais
dans les jours qui ont suivi et à faire
en sorte d'organiser ce qu'on a appelé
la grande mobilisation de l'école pour
les valeurs de la république
ou comment nous assurer qu en plus de
transmettre des savoirs l'école
transmettent bien des valeurs aux
enfants qu'elle reçoit de ce point de
vue nous avons évidemment
d'abord veiller à ce que tous les
incidents puisse être remontée dans les
meilleures conditions possibles parce
que le premier des risques que nous
courons c'est de minimiser ou de
sous-estimer le type d'incident qui
peuvent se dérouler dans les écoles et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
renforcé nos procédures en matière de
signalement des phénomènes par exemple
de radicalisation que l'on peut
constater et la coopération entre les
ministères de l'éducation nationale et
l'ensemble des services de l'état
étaient renforcés de ce point de vue là
ce qui me permet de vous dire que au 20
mai dernier nous avons eu 1 816
signalements qui avait été transmis aux
services compétents de la police ou la
justice grâce à la vigilance des
établissements scolaires qui s'approprie
de plus en plus les outils qu'on met à
leur disposition pour faire remonter ces
cas problématiques bien sûr qui dit
suffisent suspicion pardon de
radicalisation ne dit pas radicalisation
il faut faire attention nos personnels
sont invités à alerter sur leurs doutes
mais c'est ensuite le travail de la
cellule de suivi préfectoral qui doit
établir ce qui relève ou pas de la
radicalisation donc l'éducation
nationale coopère avec les services de
justice le ministère de l'intérieur
grâce en particulier à deux outils très
efficaces qui sont le premier le système
d'information qu'on appelle le civis et
puis le deuxième les enquêtes de
victimation et de climat scolaire qui
nous permette d'objectiver les faits de
violence scolaire qui peuvent se
dérouler dans les établissements nous
avons fait évoluer ses dispositifs en
novembre dernier et désormais nous
savons que chaque soir les chefs
d'établissement transmettent de façon
systématique aux autorités compétentes
les faits problématiques qui se sont
déroulées dans leur établissement
c'est ainsi qu'on arrive à ces chiffres
qui peuvent vous sembler important mais
en réalité c'est l'effet d'une
amélioration de notre système
statistique
la grande mobilisation pour les valeurs
de la république pour revenir à l
en refermant cette parenthèse du suivi
statistique ça a consisté à dire l'école
ne peut pas être seuls les enseignants
ne peuvent pas être seul pour répondre
aux fractures qu'on évoquait ou aux
défis qui sont posés à leurs élèves et
donc elle a consisté cette grande
mobilisation à regarder comment
s'appuyer davantage sur les acteurs qui
entoure l'école je pense aux
collectivités locales je pense aux
fédérations de parents d'élèves
je pense à tous ceux qui ont dit leur
disponibilité pour venir donner un coup
de main et c'est pour cela que nous
avons décidé d'ouvrir une réserve
citoyenne dans l'éducation nationale
pour permettre
ils sont déjà 4660 à s'y être inscrit à
des citoyens volontaires devenir
intervenir dans les écoles chacun sur
son expertise sur son expérience pour
aider à transmettre ses valeurs
c'est ainsi aussi que nous avons pris la
décision à partir de la rentrée scolaire
prochaine de développer dans les
établissements scolaires les service
civique des jeunes qui seront ils sont
5000 à la rentrée scolaire donc dépêché
dans les établissements pour accompagner
des projets des élèves des projets des
équipes pédagogiques
et là encore veiller à améliorer le
climat scolaire
je continue en vous disant que ce qu'ils
aient beaucoup ressorti de cette grande
mobilisation et de cette consultation
tous azimuts c'est l'importance du
principe de laïcité bien entendu ça ne
vous étonnera pas madame la présidente
le la laïcité qui doit au sein des
écoles protéger les élèves du
prosélytisme protéger aussi des
irruptions identitaire mais qui est une
laïcité qui a d'abord vocation à
organiser la cohabitation harmonieuse et
de ce point de vue là un certain
d'enseignants nous ont dit ne pas être
toujours armé outillés pour expliquer ce
qu'est la laïcité pour la transmettre
dans de bonnes conditions et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons décidé
de mieux les former à cette laïcité à
l'enseignement moral et civique que nous
introduisons à
rentrée prochaine de la primaire jusqu'à
jusqu'au lycée pour faire en sorte que
ces enseignants soient davantage en
mesure de répondre à des questions
qu'ils ont parfois eu du mal à affronter
pendant les incidents de janvier et nous
avons ainsi entre le mois d'avril et le
mois de mai déjà formés 1200 formateur
pardon ce vocabulaire mais en
l'occurrence des cadres de l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire des chefs
d'établissements des inspecteurs des
conseillers pédagogiques des référents
laïcité qui seront à leur tour amené à
former 300 mille enseignants d'ici la
fin de l'année 2015 pour répondre à ces
défis
je parlais de l'enseignement moral et
civique c'est une nouveauté importante
qui va donc voir le jour à la rentrée
prochaine
cela se traduira concrètement sur
l'ensemble d'une scolarité d'un enfant
entre le primaire et le lycée par 300
heures d'enseignement qui lui seront
délivrées non pas sous la forme d'un
enseignement magistral théorique
descendants mais d'un enseignement qui
s'appuie bien sûr un programme puisque
ce programme a été rédigé par le conseil
supérieur des programmes et donc que
nous l'avons adopté mais qui s'organise
essentiellement autour de débats car ce
qu'il est apparu c'est que c'est sous
surtout l'esprit critique des élèves
qu'il faut davantage développée pour
ensuite lui leur transmettre ces valeurs
républicaines dont nous parlons est donc
c'est au tour du débat autour de la
capacité à trier l'information a utilisé
pour ce faire les outils numériques dont
on sait que souvent noah l'information
les élèves concernés que cet
enseignement moral et civique
s'organisera l'année prochaine il sera
lui même un élément d'un tous que nous
avons qualifié de parcours citoyen qui
signifie que chaque établissement est
invité dans son projet d'établissement a
organisé pour les élèves
et bien cette possibilité au delà de cet
enseignement moral et civique de
participer à la vie démocratique
citoyenne de l'établissement de prendre
des responsabilités de développer les
relations partenariales
avec les associations qui entoure
l'établissement pour faire en sorte que
les élèves fassent l'expérience le plus
tôt possible de la citoyenneté et nous
réfléchissons en ce moment même à la
façon dont cela peut être valorisée dans
l'évaluation des élèves une deuxième
chose qui nous est apparu au delà de la
laïcité c'est le faible niveau d'un
certain nombre d'enfants d'élèves dans
l'expression en français tout simplement
d'où la priorité que nous avons décidé
d'accorder à l'enseignement de la langue
française
parce que il est vrai qu'il est
particulièrement difficile de débattre
ou de défendre ses idées lorsqu'on ne
maîtrise pas les mots c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous le verrez dans les
nouveaux programmes que nous préparons
actuellement et en particulier
d'ailleurs dans ceux qui ont déjà été
adoptées pour l'école maternelle et qui
entreront en vigueur à la rentrée
prochaine
la maîtrise du langage est devenu une
priorité avec y compris prévu de façon
inédite une évaluation en classe de ce2
dès le premier trimestre qui permettra
de vérifier les acquis des élèves pour
ensuite adapter nos enseignements
je continuerai d'ailleurs en faisant une
allusion très rapide j'ai compris qu'il
ne fallait pas trop s'y attarder mais à
la réforme du collège à moi j'ai le
droit d'accord d'accord mais en redisant
ici et que que l'objectif de la réforme
du collège c'est bien évidemment de
garantir l'acquisition des fondamentaux
ou sein desquels le français et que
l'accompagnement personnalisé en
particulier le développement du travail
en petits groupes
la refonte des programmes pour mettre
l'essentiel au coeur de ce qu'on apprend
et de ce qu'on veille à évaluer et bien
ça a vocation à renforcer cette maîtrise
du français et donc de la capacité à
développer un esprit critique à débattre
bref à devenir aussi citoyen en passant
par l'école
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire en
quelques mots je me réserve pour vos
questions mais je terminerais juste en
vous disant que cette grande
mobilisation
de l'éducation nationale autour de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
elle a eu lieu pendant donc quatre mois
en fin du mois de janvier jusqu'à
récemment puisque nous l'avons clôturé
c'était il ya quinze jours et cette
grande mobilisation elle a dépassé nos
espérances puisque partout sur le
territoire c'est cinquante mille
personnes qui ont été amenés à
s'exprimer en disant clairement à la
fois leurs attentes considérables à
l'égard de l'école sur ce sujet et en
même temps leur disponibilité je pense
que s'il ya bien une nouveauté un
peut-être un nouveau chemin à prendre
pour l'école c'est celui de l'ouverture
plus grande à ceux qui en effet qu'il
s'agisse des parents d'élèves qu'il
s'agisse des associations qu'il s'agisse
parfois des entreprises aussi se disent
prêts à venir développer chez les élèves
à la fois la motivation mais aussi la
persévérance et puis le la compréhension
d'un certain nombre de valeurs qui
parfois leur paraissent trop théorique
en particulier lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
amenés à les vivre même voilà merci
beaucoup madame la ministre pour ces
propos qui vont dans le sens je crois de
ce qu'ils seront nos préconisations et
excusez-moi si sur le collège j'ai été
un petit peu directive
c'est simplement pour qu'on ne parle pas
du latin de la langue vivante 2 de la
langue vivante 1 des landes régionales
mais bien sûr que la langue française
est une part importante de notre
commission denquête je vais donc laisser
la parole à notre rapporteur je vous
remercie
merci présidente merci madame la
ministre n'aurait accepté cette audition
de commission denquête et je tiens à
remercier tous les tous les sénateurs
présents parce que je crois que c'est
important de faire honneur au ministre
de la république
même si parfois nous sommes pas d'accord
ne rend le droit quand même de respecter
les uns et les autres est aujourd'hui la
présidente l'a bien dit ça sera pas
simplement sur la réforme du collège
même si que peut-être que les questions
peuvent être transverses
mais en tout cas ce moment aura lieu
demain donc merci vous prêter à cet
exercice
donc j'ai plusieurs questions
j'essaierai de ne pas tout les poser
pour laisser à mes collègues
l'opportunité de le faire aussi mais il
ya un à certaines dont je me dois de
d'être le transmetteur la première
question c'est par un communiqué de
presse en date du 14 janvier vous avez
annoncé que vous l'aviez tout à l'heure
avoir pris connaissance de 200 incidents
liés à la minute de silence
il a dit qu'il avait un peu plus nous
des comptes sur le fondement des
documents transmis par le ministère
comme par les différents rectorats font
état d'année d'un chiffre bien supérieur
avez vous eu connaissance de ces
incidents faut-il intégrer la dimension
ati républicaine de certains incidents
dans les enquêtes sur le climat scolaire
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question a trait aux enseignants aux
chefs d'établissements qui ont parfois
le sentiment d'être peu soutenus par
leur hiérarchie en matière de discipline
et d'atteinte aux valeurs républicaines
comment comptez-vous y remédier ensuite
dans troisième question pour de nos
auditions quelques insuffisances de
l'éducation civique juridique et sociale
nous ont été signifiées le future
anciennement morale civique devait y
remédier je déplore l'absence au sein du
programme de m6 des concepts de nation
des patries qui résulte d'un choix
idéologique délibéré du conseil
supérieur des programmes qui ne les
considère pas assez inclusif qu'en
pensez vous une semaine après l'hommage
solennel qui a pu avoir lieu au niveau
des grandes des quatre grandes figures
de la résistance quoique vous rétablir
ces concepts enfin en matière de
recrutement des personnes de leurs de
recrutement des personnels de
l'éducation nationale comment pouvez
vous intégrer l'impératif de l'adhésion
et de la capacité à faire adhérer
ou à faire partager les valeurs de la
république pourquoi ne pas restauré une
épreuve spécifique du capes qui existait
auparavant agir en fonctionnaire éthique
et responsable pour certains nous sommes
allés dans les esprits et dans les
esprits il ya une problématique peu
compliqué parce qu'il ya une
clarification des exigences en matière
de laïcité qui doit être souligné
en effet les étudiants m1 m2 b qui sont
ce qu'on appelle reçus collés ne sont
pas astreints pur respect de la laïcité
et des jeunes filles peuvent ainsi
fortement porté par don librement le
voile au cours de leur scolarité ce qui
n'est pas sans poser problème à la
différence de leurs consignes disciples
qui ont une concours qui sont élèves
fonctionnaires et qui n'ont pas le droit
comment garantir une formation adéquate
des enseignants à la transmission de la
valeur des valeurs de la république
ainsi que le respect de celle-ci au
cours de la formation initiale puis
peut-être quelles pourraient être les
traductions concrètes d'une orientation
de rétablissement de l'autorité des
maîtres et comment remettre du rituel
est de la solennité dans la scolarité
afin de lui donner du sens merci
alors ça fait beaucoup de questions me
assure donc madame la ministre vous
pouvez y répondre bien sûr dans l'ordre
dans le désordre et de la façon qui vous
intéresse puisque dans votre propos
liminaire il y avait déjà des points que
vous avez traité
bon d'abord sur les incidents donc lié à
la minute de silence je voudrais être
sûr de m'être fait bien comprendre
pardon au moment donc de cette minute de
silence ce sont environ 200 incidents
qui nous ont été remontés jeu convient
aisément que
on a connaissance que des incidents qui
nous sont remontés donc je ne suis pas
là pour vous a sonné avec force qu'il y
en a eu de sens sans doute on a utilisé
davantage en tout cas ce dont je suis
sûr c'est que nous avons passé des
instructions très claires pour que rien
ne soit minimisée sous-estimé ou non non
signalée donc je crois que 207 à peu
près raisonnable comme chiffres ce dont
je vous parlais moi tout à l'heure c'est
des signalements de radicalisation qui
sont encore quelque chose d'autre qui
est lié savez aux tentations de djihad
avec une malheureusement par un certain
nombre de jeunes et pour lequel nous
avons formé à dresser un livret aux
équipes plus enseignantes et aux chefs
d'établissement sur la façon dont on
peut identifier des signaux de
radicalisation et donc c'est ce travail
là qui nous donne le résultat que
j'évoquais des 816 signalement sur la
question dont on peut donc intégrer la
dimension anti républicaine de certains
incidents
de fait quand on parle de signaler la
radicalisation c'est bien ça que ça
recouvre donc comme je vous le disais
depuis le mois de novembre nous avons
fait évoluer nos dispositif de
signalement concrètement comment ça se
passe pour vous les ayez en tête donc
chaque jour
le chef d'établissement va faire
remonter à l'inspecteur d'académie
les incidents qui se sont déroulés dans
la journée le quai l'inspecteur
d'académie transmet à l'académie qui
ensuite elle transmet au ministère les
faits qui lui paraissent les plus graves
donc il faut bien avoir conscience bien
sûr qu'il ya des faits qui parce que
considéré comme un suffisamment grave ne
nous arrive pas mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui je crois que le message est
clair
est ce qu'il y a une réticence à
signaler au sein des établissements
scolaires oui ça peut exister évidemment
par peur de voir son établissement mal
jugé par ses supérieurs ou ou parfois
par manque d'accompagnement tout
simplement des personnels et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons voulu
notamment au lendemain des incidents
liés à la minute de silence réagir en
dépêchant des cadres aguets
ries c'est à dire notamment des
référents laïcité ou des inspecteurs
dans les établissements où il y avait eu
ce type d'incident pour reprendre la
discussion avec les élèves et ne pas
laisser s'installer le silence après
donc bien sûr que la formation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur les
questions de laïcité sert aussi par
ailleurs à aguerrir davantage les
enseignants et à passer le message qu'il
vaut mieux signaler les incidents plutôt
que les passer sous silence
un dernier mot pour vous dire que dans
la réforme du collège il est prévu
quelque chose qui est passée un peu
inaperçue mais qui est très important
qui est la généralisation de ce qu'on
appelle les enquêtes locales de climat
scolaire qui ont vocation régulièrement
dans chaque établissement à prendre le
pouls la température de la façon dont tu
es les équipes enseignantes et les
élèves vivent leur climat scolaire ce
qui nous permettra d'avancer sur des
questions comme le harcèlement bien sûr
où les violences scolaires mais qui nous
permettra aussi de répondre à ces
questions de d'incidents antirépublicain
beaucoup d'enseignants chefs
d'établissement ont fait part de leur
sentiment d'être peu soutenue en matière
de hiérarchie en matière de discipline
pardon oui ça rejoint ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est à dire que c'est une
question de messages et de signal qui
est passé et je crois que le premier
ministre moi même avons été très clairs
au lendemain des incidents janvier sur
l'enseignement moral et civique
il y est bien question de nation
vraiment le concept de nation apparaît
dans les programmes d'enseignement moral
et civique tels qu'ils ont été préparés
le sens républicain de la nation fait
partie des objets d'enseignement et
parmi les jo des objets d'enseignement
on peut aussi citer le drapeau national
l'hymne national la fête nationale ou
encore la défense nationale donc on est
bien d'accord que c'est ces programmes
ont bien vocation à transmettre un
certain nombre
de savoir de connaissances et de valeurs
aux élèves
pardon je passer d'une page à une autre
ah oui pardon oui en matière de
recrutement des personnels de
l'éducation nationale comment on intègre
l'impératif de la capacité à faire
partager les valeurs de la république ça
je l' ai absolument en tête c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai écrit à
l'ensemble des présidents de jurys des
concours de l'enseignement pour leur
demander de veiller à ce que les
thématiques de la laïcité et de la
citoyenneté trouvent leur place dans les
épreuves qu'ils font passer aux
candidats ensuite j'ai répondu oui
comment garantir une formation adéquate
des enseignants la transmission des
valeurs de la république
c'est un travail qui est en cours avec
les sp pour les ans par dans les écoles
supérieures du professeur et de
l'éducation pour votre information je
les réunis je réunis tous les directeurs
des sp dans quelques semaines pour faire
en sorte qu' il puisse y avoir une
harmonisation de leur tronc commun
puisque la difficulté à laquelle on peut
être confrontés c'est que par la loi qui
les a créés on a réclamé beaucoup d des
sp en leur demandant de traiter beaucoup
de sujets et de fait on a aujourd'hui
une hétérogénéité d'un territoire à
l'autre ou certaines vont peut-être plus
insisté sur tel ou tel sujet et cette
question de la capacité à transmettre
les valeurs républicaines nous avons
décidé qu'il fallait qu'elle fasse
partie du tronc commun de toutes les
espèces et donc nous harmonisons leurs
contenus dans quelques semaines ensemble
voilà et puis peut-être pour répondre
sur l'obligation de laïcité ou
neutralité qui qui s'impose ou pas aux
fonctionnaires stagiaires dans les sp
bien sûr les fonctionnaires stagiaires
sont tenus de respecter la neutralité
qui doit être celle des fonctionnaires
donc on il est attendu d'elle sauf par
non sauf
là alors il faut prendre le micro
ce sinon ça peut pas fonctionner sauf
les russies collégiens peuvent
intervenir justement qui n'ont pas cette
obligation de ne pas être voilées qui
peuvent l'être dans ce qu'ils ratent le
concours de la fonction publique et qui
sont réussis collet qui ne sont pas
obligés d'être en neutralité comme les
autres étudiants parler de ceux qui ne
sont pas de fait encore fonctionnaire
oui ceux qui sont en c'est parce que le
concours se situe bien sûr en l3 c'est
bien ça le sujet sauf à le changer
d'année 1 ce qui peut être une question
qu'on peut se poser
mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tant
qu'on n'est pas en master nef on n'est
pas fonctionnaire donc on n'est pas
soumis aux mêmes obligations de
neutralité
en fait le sujet c'est que on est dans
cette situation dans la même situation
que tous les étudiants à l'université et
vous savez que le non port du voile ne
s'impose pas aux étudiants à
l'université
alors merci beaucoup peut-être la
dernière question sais pas si vous avez
vu madame la ministre sur l'autorité des
maîtres
c'est pas magique mais elle a été posée
si si pardon c'est une question
importante
la question des huit vous souvenez
qu'elle avait beaucoup fait partie du
débat en janvier nous avons décidé d'y
répondre en demandant donc à chaque
établissement dans son projet
d'établissement de prendre une date de
célébration de cérémonies commémoratives
et d'y faire travailler donc leurs
élèves
d'ailleurs autour d'un projet qui y
compris comprendra la visite par exemple
d'un site mémorielle pour faire en sorte
qu' on puisse avoir un message un
discours un projet clair qu'ils soient
conduits et autour de cela bien sûr les
rites républicains la marseillaise tout
ce qui accompagne mais avec une
explication pédagogique qu'ils soient
apportées et donc les établissements
sont en train de travailler sur ces
projets qui nous permettent finalement
de répondre aussi bien la question de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
puis à celle de la transmission de la
mémoire
donc si vous voulez je vais faire des
séries de questions donc 3 3 etc
pour madame la ministre puisse les noter
et répondre de façon donc le gros
groupes et mais en même temps que tout
le monde puisse avoir la parole donc la
première question que j'ai c'est
monsieur manier bien merci madame la
présidente même le ministre chers
collègues
moi je suis d'abord très satisfait de
votre audition et d'avoir entendu les
quelques mises au point que vous avez pu
faire sur ce qui a été fait
au delà des incidents qui ont pu être
relevées après les assassinats du mois
de janvier puisque la problématique si
elle a été accentuée après ces
malheureuses fonta existait déjà
auparavant et vous avez indiqué qu'elles
sont de traitement à lèvres avait été
prévu et avait été ensuite appuyé et ont
accéléré par la suite
en tout cas moi je voudrais aujourd'hui
rappelé la position de notre groupe
socialiste dans cette mission
sans cette commission denquête les qui
est là même d'ailleurs que celle de nos
camarades dans la commission des lois
qui est aussi s'était préoccupé en
disant que bien on ne voyait pas
pourquoi une commission denquête pour
ces questions là puisque et n'y avait
pas à notre notre avis l'utilité de
faire prêter serment d'avoir toute cette
solennité autour des différentes
auditions qui ont pu être menées ici et
qui parfois ont d'ailleurs nous ont
entraînés sur des terrains assez assez
glissant est assez désagréable pour ce
qui nous concerne nous pensons que
l'école a besoin d'apaisement que les
enseignants ont certes besoin de
formation et je crois que des écoles
supérieures des professeurs à
l'éducation ont pris en compte ce besoin
de formation bien mieux qu'il ne l'a été
dans les dix dernières années grâce à la
réforme qui a été faite au mois de
juillet 2013 sur la fondation de l'école
et enfin effectivement les programmes
ont besoin de rénovations et y compris
d'intégrer des matières
comme l'enseignement moral et civique
d'une manière beaucoup plus précise qui
ne le faisait jusqu'à maintenant
alors bon je ne reviendrai pas sur les
quelques intervenants qui nous ont
parfois fait frémir y compris certains
philosophes d'autres nous ont fait
plaisir
philosophe aussi j'ai viseur bidart par
exemple nous avons tant mieux
avec beaucoup de passion dans cette dans
cette salle il ya peu de temps
mais moi je suis un peu inquiet par les
diatribes parfois à peine voilée de
notre reporter qui parfois font des
diatribes sévère contre le pédagogisme
c'est pas cher collègue si vous êtes
laissés entraîner le pédagogisme en fait
la pédagogie ça existe pédagogisme c'est
une dérive mais je crois que dans
l'école aujourd'hui les enseignants ils
ont déjà assez à faire de la pédagogie
et je crois que y ait beaucoup se
blesser pédagogistes que vous
sanctionnez vous nous dit souvent qu'il
y à des baisses de niveau qu'on remet en
cause d'excellence et que l'école ne
peut éduquer ce n'est pas son rôle
premier qu'elle doit d'abord instruire
non mais c'est ce que vous avez dit mon
cher collègue est gelée relevé
moi je suivais mes camarades durs et
michel a posé la question mais je pense
qu il faut planter le décor parce que
monsieur grosperrin et le plante le
décor souvent mais moi je voudrais le
planter alors je viendrai je ne
reviendrai pas là dessus mais pour nous
il ya eu un certain nombre de d'excès le
langage et qui pourrait laisser penser
que on met un peu l'école à feu et à
sang après ses graves événements du mois
de janvier et qu'on en a profité parfois
pour essayer de faire sinon le procès au
moins la mise en cause de l'institution
scolaire certainement des enseignants
puisque je vous le faire est observée
les syndicats s'inquiètent aussi et
parfois de toutes ces observations qui
sont faites sur leur travail
et pourtant comme l'a dit ici monsieur
léonais qui est directeur central
adjoint de la sécurité publique camp
lorsqu'il a été auditionné il n'y avait
pas autant d'incidents que ce qu'on
aurait bien voulu nous faire croire et
je crois que cette commission enquête
elle avait été faite essentiellement
pour démontrer
parce que le ministère la réponse du
ministère ne suffisait pas qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus d'incidents que ce qu'on
avait pu faire remonter or aujourd'hui
bien je crois que tout le monde sait à
peu près d'accord pour dire qu'il n'y a
pas
lieu de faire tout c'est tout enfin tout
c'est vous et des bas même s'ils sont
intéressants parfois puisque les
auditions sont toujours intéressantes
mais toujours de mettre autant de
solennité et de faire prêter serment
pour dire des choses tout à fait simple
qui effectivement que nous connaissons
bien et que nous rencontrons lorsque
nous allons dans les écoles alors hier
le ministre moi je suis content vous
ayez pu le rassurer je l'espère notre
rapporteur pour ce qui nous concerne
donc nous ne cautionnons pas les mises
en cause des enseignants de l'école
nous nous associons pas un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été dites lors
de ses auditions alors de ses
commentaires et nous prendrons notre nos
dispositions lorsque ce rapport sera
remis nous attendre avec beaucoup
d'impatience de connaître le contenu qui
sera dé vous nous l'espérons bien qui
sera dévoilée bientôt devant cette
commission
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui madame la
ministre nous préciser je crois vous
avez déjà répondu à beaucoup de ces
questions mais comment nous pouvons
aujourd'hui montrer aux élèves aux
parents d'élèves
comment pouvant s que montrer que
l'école vous vraiment a besoin d'eux
dans le climat serein et qu'il faut
laisser à la porte de l'école
aujourd'hui toutes les questions qui
sont d'ordre cultuel et laïcité
effectivement s'impose
malheureusement c'est une chose que l'on
dit souvent mais il faut que cela rentre
vraiment dans les faits que l'école soit
vraiment inspiré et plein de cette
valeur de la laïcité enfin comment dans
la formation des enseignants pouvons
nous affirmer et dessiner encore mieux
justement une laïcité tout à fait strict
mais toujours gardé un accueil
bienveillant de nos élèves qu'ils soient
collégiens qu'ils soient lycéens ou même
qu'ils soient étudiants sur le prêt à
porter toujours merci merci donc la
deuxième question c'est monsieur carle
qui va l'imposer dans par respect pour
le temps imparti à la ministre weil et
de cours je vous remercie
merci madame président durée de deux
questions madame la ministre la première
là paraît simple mais la réponse peut
être un peu moins c'est où commence et
où s'arrête l'école et donc où se
commence et où s'arrête où s'appliquent
les règles qui concerne l'école pourquoi
je vous pose cette question parce que
les enseignants que nous avons
rencontrés nous ont fait pas
effectivement des difficultés qu'ils ont
face à des signes d'un ostentatoire qui
importe atteinte à la laïcité et se
sentent et je peux confirmer ce qu'elle
dit le rapporteur pas suffisamment
soutenus par leur hiérarchie
mais où ils ont des difficultés c'est à
l'extérieur des murs qu'en est il donc d
accompagnement pour les sorties
scolaires ou les accompagnements pour
les activités culturelles et sportives
quid des conseils de classe et là ils
nous ont dit qu'ils voulaient de la
clarté
deuxième question vous l'avez dit
l'école c'est une caisse de résonance de
la société des soubresauts de la société
qu'elle a ses responsabilités mais elle
n'est pas seule responsable il ya la
famille
1 il ya aussi j'allais dire
l'environnement de l'école
or on met des corps des sommes
considérables dans chacune de ces
politiques l'école votre budget 6 66
milliards je crois la politique de la
ville c'est plus de 40 milliards
la famille c'est aussi une somme
considérable il semblerait que y'a pas à
dire suffisamment d'efficacité et un
manque de cohérence d'entre ces
politiques est ce qu'il faudrait pas
avoir une vision transversale pour que
ces politiques plus de synergie et la
troisième question de cette première
série madame blanc des merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre je te
questions sur votre politique et de
questions plutôt sur votre opinion sur
la réunion qui va avoir lieu dsp dont je
me réjouis qu'elle flèche les valeurs de
la république comme un élément
indispensable du tronc commun
je vous demande si vous avez prévu
d'inciter les directeurs à associer des
acteurs de l'éducation populaire qui
sont quand même très féru de
l'enseignement du respect de l'autre par
l'exemple de la culture de l'engagement
associations de ces acteurs qui avaient
été prévus dans la loi refondation de
l'école même chose sur l'évaluation dont
nous attendons les avis du ministère le
csp avait dit l'importance de mêlée
rigueur et exigence
et puis vient veillance afin que l'élève
comprennent ce qui lui manquait ce qu'il
est acquis mais surtout qu'il se sente
respecté je pense au secrétaire général
de l'enseignement catholique qui nous
disait écrire copine nul c'est pas la
dignité de l'élève c'est pas les valeurs
de la république quoi donc voilà est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des indications là
dessus deux choses que nous avons
entendu en suggestion et sur laquelle je
vous consulte
n'y aurait-il pas pertinence d'une
charte d'entrée en profession un peu à
la manière du serment d'hippocrate pour
les médecins ou les enseignants
déclarait qu'il s'engage à faire valoir
telle et telle chose ça me semble
important et un détail particulier à
notre république aujourd'hui tout le
monde est d'accord sur la laïcité les
valeurs de la république mais il ya
quand même encore le concordat je me
garderai bien ni attaquer ce n'est pas
le lieu
simplement dans les départements du
concordat il y a des horaires
d'enseignement religieux dont l'islam au
passage est d'ailleurs prohibées ce qui
pose un petit problème mais ces horaires
ne sont ils pas aujourd'hui à gommer au
profil de le mc ou est-ce que ça va être
compatibles merci madame la ministre si
vous voulez bien répondre
merci d'abord pour commencer par
monsieur manier que je remercie cette
question du climat scolaire en effet de
la façon dont on s'assure que l'école
soit un lieu sanctuarisé dans lequel
règne la laïcité c'est à dire qu'on
transforme bien l'enfant en élèves qu'on
lui demande de laisser à la porte de
l'école ces attributs confessionnelles
c'est une question absolument majeur
parce qu'on voit bien que de là découle
aussi la qualité du climat scolaire la
capacité des enfants à vivre apprendre à
vivre ensemble et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis 2012
loin des procès qui nous sont faits
parfois nous n'avons cessé de promouvoir
la laïcité la charte de la laïcité a
posé dans tous les établissements
scolaires ça n'existait pas avant et je
peux vous le dire parce que j'étais
encore hier à nancy dans une petite
école en plein milieu d'un quartier en
zone urbaine sensible
avec cette charte qui voilà qui était au
vu et au su de tous et qui s'imposent
pas simplement aux enfants mais aussi
aux parents tous les matins quand ils
déposent leurs enfants
il ya ces mots simples qui ont été
pensés pour l'être pour être compris de
tous qui désormais 10 ce qu'est la
laïcité donc je redis ici que ses patins
c'est pas un principe d'exclusion c'est
un principe de cohabitation harmonieuse
et au delà de cette charte de la laïcité
nous avons décidé dans les mesures que
nous avons adoptées au lendemain des
attentats et de cette grande
mobilisation de faire du 9 décembre
désormais la journée nationale de la
laïcité qui sera célébrée dans tous les
établissements et je crois que c'est
important à souligner parce que ça veut
dire on parlait tout à l'heure de rite
républicain
mais s'il est bien une valeur de la
république a célébré à faire connaître
et à faire aimer aux enfants c'est bien
celle de laïcité
cette journée on sera l'occasion et puis
je le disais les enseignants avaient
besoin d'être formés c'est pour ça que
nous avons lancé ce grand plan de
formation à la laïcité que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure qui a déjà concerné 1200
formateur et qui concernera donc trois
cent mille enseignants d'ici la fin de
l'année
ils ont aussi besoin
d'avoir ces principes simples de laïcité
comme base de relations avec les parents
et c'est pourquoi nous avons prévu que
désormais à chaque rentrée scolaire les
parents seront invités à signer le
règlement intérieur et la charte de la
laïcité pour être bien assuré qu'on
parle d'elles mêmes choses et qu'ils
comprennent quelles sont les règles
qu'on fait respecter à leurs enfants sur
la question de monsieur carle où
commence et où ça va être l'école c'est
très juste vous avez raison ce qu'il est
apparu aussi dans la grande mobilisation
c'est que ceux qui fragilisait les
discours des professeurs notamment sur
ces questions de laïcité c'est que
parfois les adultes qui entourent les
enfants ne portent pas forcément les
mêmes discours et que du coup les
enfants évidemment sont toujours très
contente de pouvoir créer des coins
entre les adultes et donc il nous faut
veiller à ce que non seulement bien sûr
les enseignants et les parents disent la
même chose ça on l'a tous en tête d'où
la nécessité de promouvoir ce qu'on
appelle la coéducation mais aussi que
les enseignants et les éducateurs que
sont amenés à rencontrer les enfants
dans le cadre des animations
périscolaires par exemple ou des
associations d'éducation populaire
disent la même chose sur ces questions
de valeurs de la république et laïcité
c'est la raison pour laquelle s'agissant
de laïcité on a décidé que toutes les
ressources pédagogiques que nous
développons pour former nos enseignants
à transmettre la laïcité
nous les mettons à disposition des
acteurs qui nous entourent je pense aux
collectivités locales par exemple pour
que les animateurs du périscolaire aussi
bénéficient de ce même accompagnement et
qu'on parle bien de la même chose sur la
base des mêmes ressources
donc on y travaille avec l'association
des maires de france dans le cadre des
plans éducatif territoriaux que l'on
construit pour les rythmes éducatif mais
je crois que c'est c'est au fond s'il ya
bien un mot qui est ressorti de toute la
consultation de ces quatre derniers mois
sur les territoires c'est décloisonner
décloisonner arrêté de fonctionner en
silo l'éducation nationale qui a ses
propres règles les services de santé
leurs propres règles et c est donc ce
sujet de laïcité en est une bonne
illustration tous les adultes doivent
parler la même
quand on parle de laïcité aux enfants
parler la même langue ça veut pas dire
pour faire le lien avec votre question
suivante être sourd à ce qui peut se
dire parfois et ne pas faire un effort
de compréhension j'en viens à la
question des accompagnatrices de sorties
scolaires
il ya moi je me jette la pierre à
personne
un de mes prédécesseurs en l'occurrence
chatel avait fait adopter une circulaire
dans laquelle il précisé qu' il fallait
lutter contre le prosélytisme à l'école
et que lorsque des parents des mères en
l'occurrence porter le foulard et
qu'elle se proposait pour être
accompagné atterrissent scolaire il ne
fallait pas les y autoriser parce qu'on
considérait cela comme du prosélytisme
on a vu les effets que ça a eu sur le
terrain
quand je dis que je ne jette la pierre à
personne c'est que je ne reproche à
personne de tenter quelque chose mais
ensuite il faut évaluer ce qu'on fait et
les effets que ça a eu sur le terrain tu
sais que ça a été terriblement
contre-productif c'est à dire que ça
braquer des générations entières
d'enfants contre même le principe de
laïcité or si on croit au principe de
laïcité mais je crois qu'on doit veiller
avant tout à ce que les enfants il y
adhèrent parce que si on donne
l'impression de leur faire violence et
en l'occurrence le fait de refuser à
leur maire d' accompagner bénévolement
une sortie scolaire et donc de la
stigmatiser de la mettre de côté au
simple motif d'une tenue vestimentaire
sans même qu'elle ait fait preuve de
prosélytisme particulier et bien c'est
une façon de braquer les enfants
d'évidence et donc c'est pour cela que
en effet j'ai revu la position sur ce
sujet je voudrais très clair sur ma
position à moi je suis opposé à toute
forme de prosélytisme et donc je le dis
je les dis aux équipes enseignantes et
aux chefs d'établissements dès lors
qu'il y à du prosélytisme d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient politiques ou religieux ou
autre il faut bien évidemment s'opposer
à la venue dans l'établissement ou à
l'accompagnement par un parent
d'une sortie scolaire mais quand il n'y
a pas ce prosélytisme quand on est
simplement face à un parent qui n'est
pas un agent du service public donc qui
n'est pas tenu par les mêmes règles de
neutralité
quand on est face à une volonté de
coopérer des parents je crois que nous
devons mais tout mettre en oeuvre pour
favoriser la coéducation favoriser le
travail partenarial de l'école avec les
parents c'est la raison pour laquelle
que j'ai souhaité que dans ce type de
situation là les équipes fassent preuve
du discernement qu'on attend d'elle et
est favori cette coopération plutôt que
de la rejeter
de manière générale le maître mot en
matière de laïcité c'est discernement
c'est d'ailleurs une preuve de confiance
qui est faite aux équipes enseignantes
que de leur dire il ya certes des règles
qu'on définit au niveau national
uniformément mais ensuite il ya la
réalité du terrain et c'est aussi adam
dans le détail de la vie que ses équipes
savent comment se comporter par exemple
vous aurez noté que celle ci semble de
cette jeune fille à la jupe longue qui
dans un établissement scolaire a vu ses
parents convoqués au motif qu' elles
étaient elles perturbé
eh bien j'ai pris la défense et le
soutien de l'équipe enseignante parce
que de fait j'ai pu constater qu' il y
avait perturbations il y avait ainsi
n'en est que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous demandons aux enseignants
de faire remonter les incidents de ne
pas les minimiser donc quand ils ont
lieu oui il faut convoquer les parents
oui il faut adopter des sanctions
éducatives pédagogiques et non il ne
faut pas laisser passer les provocations
mais c'est une question de discernement
et ça n'est évidemment pas au motif de
la couleur ou de la longueur de la jupe
que cette jeune fille a été prise à
partie c'est bien parce qu'elle avait un
comportement qui n'étaient pas
acceptables donc discernement et pour
que les enseignants puissent faire
preuve de ce discernement formation l'a
dit en initiale dans les espèces on l'a
dit en continu comme je l'évoquais et
puis accompagnement c'est à dire pouvoir
se reposer sur des spécialistes au fond
de ces questions là et c'est la raison
pour laquelle depuis 2012 nous avons
développé dans chaque académie des
référents laïcité qui là encore
n'existait pas auparavant donc des
monsieur ou madame qui sont
spécifiquement chargé d'accompagner les
équipes sur ces sujets madame blandin
sur la question de désespérer du fait
d'associer les acteurs de l'éducation
populaire
oui d'abord je voudrais vraiment insisté
sur le fait que le ministère de
l'éducation nationale soutient beaucoup
les acteurs de l'éducation populaire
enfin vous le savez évidemment vous mais
c'est pas forcément su à l'extérieur et
on le fait parce que de fait
il ya un travail efficace qui est
conduit par ces associations et nous
souhaitons en effet développer leur
implication dans les formations qui
seront délivrés par les sp sur sur le
reste vous m'interrogez sur notre
calendrier en matière d'évaluation
je redis ici que la réforme du collège
que nous avons conduite est un tout il
s'agit bien à la rentrée 2016 d'avoir à
la fois une organisation du collège des
pratiques pédagogiques qui évolue je ne
reviens pas dans le détail des
programmes qui sont revu et repensé pour
mettre l'acquisition des fondamentaux en
leur coeur et qui sont pensés en
cohérence avec les nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques pour dire les choses
clairement dès lors qu'on introduit de
l'interdisciplinarité il faut que ça se
retrouve dans les programmes par exemple
et pour boucler la boucle et que tout
cela fasse un ensemble cohérent il
s'agit bien aussi de réformer
l'évaluation donc d'avoir un nouveau
diplôme du brevet qui en effet soit à la
fois exigeants clairement et qui en même
temps que soit stimulant parce que nous
estimons que l'évaluation elle est faite
aussi pour encourager faire progresser
les élèves
et puis un diplôme national du brevet
qui tout simplement conforte les
évolutions que nous avons introduites
typiquement si dans notre réforme du
collège nous voulons mettre l'accent
davantage sur la maîtrise de l'oral en
plus de celle de l'écrit mettre l'accent
davantage sur la capacité des élèves à
coopérer à travailler ensemble à mener
des projets il faut que cela se traduise
ensuite parce que le brevet vient
sanctionner évaluer et donc c'est
l'objet de cette réforme du pont du
brevet pardon qui va être adoptée
prochainement et qui entrera en vigueur
aussi à la rentrée 2016 j'ai noté les
dernier point juste un mot j'ai une
haute et là l'idée d'une charte d'entrée
en enseignement jeu si vous l'aviez
formulé comme ça mais ça que je les
notés mais je trouve que l'idée est
intéressante je pense qu'elle mérite
d'être creusée et puis sur la question
de l'enseignement religieux
j'insiste sur l'enseignement laïc du
fait religieux
donc j'avais indiqué après janvier que
je souhaitais le voit renforcée dans les
nouveaux programmes puisqu'on a d'une
certaine façon la chance de voir
l'ensemble des programmes qui sont
refondus donc le csp que vous connaissez
bien le conseil supérieur des programmes
a reçu cette instruction et le travail
est en cours pour faire en sorte que cet
enseignement laïque du fait religieux
soit bien présent sur les trois
monothéismes
et il ne s'agit pas là encore
d'apprendre une fois aux élèves mais de
développer leur esprit critique à
l'égard de ce qui peut s'écrire en la
matière
merci voilà vous venez de suivre
l'audition de la ministre de l'éducation
nationale nadja de vallaud belkacem par
la commission d' enquête du sénat sur le
service public de l'éducation et la
perte de repères républicain devant les
sénateurs la ministre est revenue sur sa
vision de l'école comme vecteur des
valeurs républicaines une audition que
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr dans
quelques instants vous avez rendez vous
avec votre émission politique preuve par
3 présenté par michel grossiord et
perrine tarneaud leurs invités ce soir
françois baroin sénateurs les
républicains et président de
l'association des maires de france très
bonne cible des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires